With that out of the way, this brings us to the end of our chaos clothing tutorial.
Just a real quick recap of what we went over. We first started out with what is
chaos clothing. We then took a look at creating content for chaos clothing
inside of your digital content creation program of choice. We then
took a look at the chaos clothing editor overview. We then finished that
up by looking at the chaos clothing exercise and finally finished this
entire tutorial series with some chaos clothing tips and tricks. That is all
that I have for you today. Again, my name is Sam Deiter. I'm a senior instructor
with Epic Games. It's my pleasure having you in class and I hope to see
you next time.